So it's my pleasure to
introduce Daniel MacArthur,
who is from just down the street
and has been instrumental in
creating a extremely
valuable resource,
that based on the title of his
talk, I think he's going to tell
us about and probably how it's
changing the world, so great.
>> Cool, thank you Jennifer and
thanks for the opportunity to be
here today it's a great pleasure
to be here, of course.
So Jennifer mentioned I
work just down the road at
the Broad Institute.
I have a lab, but
I also spend a fair bit of time
over at Mass General Hospital.
We have two focuses, one is on
rare disease diagnosis, which
you've heard a lot about and
I'm not gonna talk about today.
And the second,
as Jennifer mentioned,
is thinking about ways in which
we can build up very large
collections of genetic variation
from the general population.
Primarily, with
the focus of using
these as reference databases to
understand what variants do and
which ones are most important
for causation of rare disease.
And I think I wanted to
just start with generally
framing a sense of why I'm so
excited about human genetics
as we stand right now.
I think it's actually the most
exciting field that's
going on at the moment.
And it's the most exciting time
to be working in human genetics.
And that's because human
genetics provides us a way of
moving back and forth between
two very different and
powerful kinds of information.
So we are becoming
increasingly good,
as you've heard from
other speakers today,
at layering information
across the genome.
So here in this random
screenshot from
the USOC Genome Browser, we
have some chunk of the genome.
And for
each base in the human genome,
we have information about if
that's present in a gene or not.
If so, where that gene
is actually expressed.
If it's in a non coding region,
whether that is also a
regulatory region that may play
some role in regulating
gene expression.
And this information is
increasing thanks to information
like ENCODE and
Epigenomics Roadmap and GTEx and
other resources.
And then another type of
information that we as
the broader biomedical community
have become very good at
collecting is information
about human phenotypes.
We now have millions of people
around the world who have been
collected in large,
often national scale bio banks.
And these people have
a whole variety of different
bits of information
collected about them.
And these can range from
information about particular
diseases they've
been diagnosed with,
which may be stored in a more or
less well formatted fashion.
So all sorts of electronic
medical record data,
prescription registers,
quantitative trade data and
questionnaires.
And then in many cases, a whole
bunch of interesting and rich
biological or functional genomic
data, like transcript mix or
metabeilomix that can give us
some insight into the biology of
those individuals.
And human genetics is cool,
in part, because it provides us
with a way of moving back and
forth between these two
kinds of information.
So the traditional,
forward genetics way of
doing human genetics,
is that we would collect people
on the bases of phenotype.
So do something like what
Gill just talked about,
identify certain families who
have some interesting and
very rare disease,
group those people and
then see what pieces of
DNA they have in common.
That is what variation they have
in common, and use that to zoom
in on particular genes that
may underlay their disease.
This has been an incredibly
productive approach.
We now know more than 4,000
genes associated with
Mendelian diseases.
And many thousands of regions in
the genome that are associated
with common complex disorders
like type 2 diabetes, for
instance.
But as we start to build
up these big bio banks, and
we start to sequence, that is
do DNA sequencing, on more
of the people in those bio
banks, it becomes feasible to
start thinking about moving in
the opposite direction as well.
That is to find people and
group them on the basis
of their genotype.
So find, for instance, all
the people who have particular
disruptive mutations in
a particular gene, group them on
that basis and then look to see
what they have in common in
terms of their traits, is what
we would call reverse genetics.
It's a very common approach to
doing things in model organisms
where we can actually
genetically engineer particular
mice to lack a specific gene,
for instance, and
then see what happens to them
when we knock that gene out.
Now, of course, in humans,
we can't do genetic engineering.
But what we can do is take
advantage of the enormous amount
of genetic variation that exists
in the general population.
And the amount of variation that
exists is genuinely staggering.
You can calculate actually
relatively easily based on what
we know about
the distribution of
mutation rates across the genome
and how many people exist.
That effectively, any given
single-nucleotide substitution,
that is at a particular
position in the genome or
changing to an A, or a C, or
a G, almost certainly exists out
there among the 7 billion people
that exist in the population.
So that means humanity in effect
represents an enormous natural
experiment where we have tried,
certainly not the complete space
of human genomic sequence, but
perturbations across many
different regions of the genome.
And all we need to do to
understand exactly what effect
each of those perturbations
have is sequence the genomes
of all 7 billion people on
the face of the planet.
Hook those into a big
electronic medical record
system that allows
us to go back and
recontact people based
on that information.
And then systematically collect,
for instance,
all the knockouts in
a particular gene and
see what they have in common.
Now, we are not,
as you guys know,
anywhere close to being able to
sequence 7 billion genomes yet,
although that will
happen eventually.
But what we can do is to start
to accumulate information
that has been collected across
now well over 2 million people
who've had either their
whole genome sequenced or
in many cases their exomes.
That is a particular technology
that allows us to look
just at the protein coding
bits of the genome.
So this 2 million
number is a lower,
sort of ball park estimate.
These 2 million people have
been sequenced through a whole
host of different academic and
commercial ventures and this
information is being generated
in sites around the world,
collected for a whole variety
of different projects.
But just to give you an idea
about how fast that information
is growing, curves like this I'm
sure have been presented earlier
today, but this is information
just from one place
the Broad Institute, again, a
couple of blocks down the road.
You can see the growth in the
number of genomes that have been
sequenced from 2009 to 2016.
This information's about,
I guess about 8 months,
10 months out of date.
Over here we have the number
of exomes sequenced.
And the two bits of information
you should be taking from these
curves is firstly the number at
the top, which it tells us we
had at the end of last year
sequenced about 70,000 genomes
and over a quarter of
a million human exomes.
It's a staggering
amount of data, but
also the shape of this curve.
In 2016 we sequenced more
genomes than in all years
previously combined.
And so the trajectory at which
we are generating this data is
truly staggering.
Now, ideally what we wanna do
is to take all these 2 million
sequenced individuals and
house them all together in one
big unified bio bank that would
allows us to link between
genotype and phenotype, but
this turns out to be difficult
for all sorts of reasons.
There's mundane obstacles
associated with moving data from
one place to another.
It turns out because these
samples have been collected over
many decades, often well before
they were sequenced, the consent
that they were consented under
is often inadequate to justify
very large scale data sharing.
And in fact, a lot of my life is
dealing with inadequate consent
and data use permissions.
There are objections to data
sharing, so much of this data
has been generated in
an industry setting and
that is often regarded
as a trade secret.
You guys, I'm sure,
will be shocked to learn
there are even some academics
that are not fully on board
with the idea of sharing data,
so this can be challenging.
And then a final problem that we
face is the fact that different
centers who generate this
data tend to process and
perform variant polling across
that data in idiosyncratic ways.
So if we were to just take the
outputs of all of each of these
different centers and try to
merge together this matrix of 2
million sets of genotypes,
we would end up with a variant
core set that was dominated
by technical differences
between centers, as opposed to
interesting biological
differences between people,
which of course is not useful.
So to resolve at least some of
these problems we have been
working I guess for about the
last four years on building up
large reference databases
of human variation,
leveraging the expertise and the
data that exists at the Broad.
So when we started this exercise
back in 2012 there were two
large public data sets
of human variation.
We had the 1,000
Genomes Project.
Which contained about two and
half thousand, low coverage,
whole human genomes from
a variety of different
populations.
It's a fantastic project.
We also have the NHLBI's Exome
Sequencing Project, which has
generated exome sequencing from
about six and half thousand
individuals from either European
or African American descent.
And so to cut a very long story
short, we began analyzing rare
disease patients using these
resources and rapidly found they
were too small, and in many
cases, too old to be good
comparison data sets for
our rare disease patients.
So we built, over a relatively
painful 18 month period,
our first large core
set of human exomes.
This is called the Exome
Aggregation Consortium, or
ExAC data set,
that was released back in 2014.
And that contained information
from just over 60,000
human exomes.
And then almost to the day two
years later, in October last
year, we released
an updated version of ExAC,
this is now called the Genome
Aggregation database, or gnomAD.
Because we like
slightly curious and
idiosyncratically capitalized
names.
And this now contains about
twice the number of human exomes
and for the first time in Nomad,
we've also included a whole
collection of human genomes.
So providing information about
the distribution of variation
across the noncoding,
that is the non-protein
coding bits of the genome.
So it's important to note
that we do not sequence these
samples.
These data all come from
various studies, and I'll list
the PIs and where these
samples come from in a minute.
For many different studies,
we aggregate that data and
we put it through the same
processing pipeline.
Then we do what we call,
joint variant coding across all
samples simultaneously or less.
And that allows us to get
a harmonized code set across
these large numbers of samples.
And this is a testament
to the engineering and
scaling work that's been
done at the Broad Institute.
So this is brief summary
of the pipeline.
I'm not gonna go through
the details about how a variant
calling pipeline works.
I don't think it's hugely
relevant for this audience.
I guess it is worth
emphasizing on this slide,
we start with raw data.
We go through an individual
sample variant,
genotyping variant
calling approach.
We then do joint genotyping
across large numbers of samples.
There's a variant
recalibration approach.
And then we have
this final call set,
this very big variant call file,
or VCF file,
that stores all the data
across these samples.
So the thing I did
wanna mention, though,
is this is a lot of data.
So the raw data that's gone into
this project over the exome data
which is on the left-hand side,
and the genome data on the
right-hand side is about three
petabytes of raw sequence data.
And that condenses down to about
a 40 terabyte variant core file
which is actually still a
staggeringly large file that we
have to work with.
Many people were involved
in generating and
analyzing these data.
And I wanted to
particularly call out
the Broad Data Sciences Platform
for building the tools that
allowed us to call
variants in this scale.
But also incredibly
importantly a tool kit called
the Hale System which was
built at the Broad Institute.
Which Alex here in the room is a
representative of the Hale team.
And Hale was absolutely critical
in being able to go from this 40
terabyte VCF, and
actually do important things
with it like quality control,
and assess the variants, and
release data in a useful
way to the public.
And a huge thanks
to all the members of the team
who contributed to this as well.
So it's worth emphasizing
who's actually ended up in
these databases.
So we have these rough, over
135,000 people across the exomes
and the genomes who were
in the gnomAD database.
These people are not
necessarily well.
They come primarily from
case control studies of
relatively common complex
adult onset diseases.
The big hitters in terms of
the major diseases included in
the database
are type 2 diabetes,
early onset myocardial
infarction or heart attack,
and neuropsychiatric conditions
like schizophrenia and bipolar.
So about half the people are
controls for those studies and
about half the people are cases.
Now we have as best we can
depleted this resource
of people known to have
severe pediatric disease.
So the types of underlying
diseases that Gil talked about
as well as their first
degree relatives.
But of course some individuals
in this cohort will still
be ill or will go on
to become ill later on
through adult onset
rare disorders.
However, we think that the
levels of severe disease within
this population are probably
broadly comparable to
the general
population as a whole.
So this is a reasonable
reference data set if you're
interested in figuring out, if a
variant that is present in your
rare disease patient is present
in the general population.
And if so, what frequency it
has within that population.
And I won't go into detail
about some of the work
we're doing here.
But about 40% of the samples
have some clinical data
available.
In fact, about a third of
the samples have consent that is
consistent with recontact.
So for
a subset of these individuals,
we can actually go back.
If we find interesting
genotypes,
we can actually go back and
see what sorts of phenotypes
they have, or at least
get some limited information
about their clinical status.
So I'm showing this slide purely
to indicate that this has
been a project that is
involved in an enormous number
of data donators, so
principal investigators who have
allowed their data to be
used in this process.
I think at last count we're up
to about 107 PIs who signed
an MOU that allows their data
to be used in this project.
So a huge thanks to them and,
of course,
to our funders for
making this possible.
So this is
one of the first things we did
across the gnomAD data set.
It's a principal
component analysis,
basically just showing the first
three principal components,
which correspond,
broadly speaking,
to geographical ancestry
across the gnomAD individuals.
Here we've generated this based
on about just over 50,000
well-called single
nucleotide variants.
And we have inferred the
population labels using a random
forest approach with a set of
about 40,000 people of so-called
known ancestry.
So what we can see in this plot
is that we have a pretty diverse
set of individuals who
have been sequenced here.
A big cloud of individuals
of European ancestry,
we have clusters corresponding
to Finnish ancestry and
Ashkenazi Jewish.
Big cloud up here of South Asian
individuals, and we also have
clusters corresponding to
individuals of Latino ancestry,
African, and African-American
as well as East Asian ancestry.
So this is by no means a
comprehensive sampling of human
genetic diversity.
In fact we're not even close.
We're missing, for instance,
enormous swathes of
diversity in Africa.
The Middle East is missing,
and this is because of the
ascertainment vices that have
gone into generating the samples
that are going to have gone into
this dataset.
But what we do have is
thousands of individuals, for
each of a set of relatively
major continental groups.
And this is really
important if we wanna
be able to assign relatively
confidently population frequency
estimates for
variants that we find in
rare disease patients
from those continents.
And if you're interested
in accessing the data,
one of the key principles of
ExAc and gnomAD, actually right
from the very beginning was that
we wanted this to be a resource,
not just for us, but for
anyone who wanted to look up
variants on their patients.
So you can go to
gnomad.broadinstitute.org.
You can look up
your favorite gene.
I’m sure you guys all
have a favorite gene.
When you do, you will find these
blue peaks that correspond to
the coverage across the exomes.
And the green line represents
the coverage across the genomes,
across the exomes of
that particular gene.
Below that is a big long
table of variants that tells
you every variant that we have
discovered within that gene
across both the coding and
the noncoding regions.
And you can click on those
to learn more about how
common they are in
the population and
how confident we are that
they're actually real.
Including for most variants
actually a snapshot of the role
read support,
telling us that that variant
is actually a genuine variant.
I mean, you can also download
a site's PCF that gives you
a complete list of every
variant that we've called
as well as its frequency
across populations.
And that's available for use in
any setting without embargo or
any restrictions
whatsoever on use.
So I wanted to talk about some
of scientific things that we
can do once we have a collection
of 135,000 exomes and genomes.
One of the things that
we spent a lot of time thinking
about is ways that we can look
at not just the variants that
are present in this data set.
But also the variants that
are missing from the data set.
In that sense,
I mean, informatively
missing from the data set.
And so to do this,
we worked very closely with
Caitlin Symoka, a graduate
student in Mark Daily's lab.
She had developed a statistical
model that allowed her to
predict, actually with
quite high confidence,
given non-mutation rates how
many variants of a particular
functional class we should
expect to see in each gene in
the genome in a collection
of 60,000 people, or
135,000 people.
And so this allows us to say,
you can see in this plot here
for a variant type like
synonymous variants, for
instance, which are variants
that are found within coding
regions, but don't change the
amino acid sequence, how many
synonymous variants we would
expect to see in each gene.
That's shown here on the x-axis
under Caitlin's model.
Each dot here is a gene.
And on the y-axis, we have the
number of variants of that type
that were actually observed
in the 60,000 people in ExAC.
And you can see that the fit for
synonymous experience
is extremely good,
an r squared of about 0.98.
And so
that tells us that this model
is actually very well calibrated
for variants that aren't subject
to strong natural selection.
But that relationship
begins to break down.
In fact, it breaks down very
severely as we start looking at
variants that do actually have
a functional impact on genes.
So here we're focusing
on genes that are,
what we call,
loss of function genes.
That is they're
predicted to break
the function of
a protein coding gene.
And you can see
here that the relationship
here is far from linear.
Almost all the genes in
the genome have fewer loss of
function variants that we
would expect to see by chance.
And it is not surprising at all.
What it tells us is that for
most genes in the genome,
loss of function
variants are bad.
And so as a result,
they tend to be removed from the
population by natural selection.
What's cool about this, though,
is that with 60,000 people and
even more so
with 135,000 people,
we can actually say for many
of the genes in the genome how
far below the line
does that gene fall.
And therefore, how strong
is the action of natural
selection that's acting on
what's the function variants
in that particular gene.
So that really gives us a
measure about how critical that
gene is and
how bad it is when you break it.
So just to give you two
examples, this is a gene called
DYNC1H1 where we know exactly
what happens when you break it,
heterozygous Missense and loss
of function variance in this
gene result in some pretty nasty
neurodevelopmental disorders
including seizure disorders and
intellectual disability.
Kaitlin's model is very
well calibrated for
synonymous variance
in this gene.
The gene is missing about
two-thirds of the missense
variants and virtually all of
the loss of function variance
that we would expect
to be see by chance.
We've spent,
would expect to see 161.
In fact, we only see four.
And of those four,
two of them are artifacts.
One is a sequencing error.
One is an annotation error.
There are in fact two people
who appear to be carrying
loss of function
variants in this gene.
We don't have finished updated
data about them and in fact,
they may actually suffer
from these disorders.
So that's when we know what
happens when you break the gene.
This is a gene where we don't
know what happens in humans.
And this gene, UBL5, we know is
involved in ubiquinone pathway.
We know if you knock
it out in mice,
it kills them during
embryogenesis.
But there's no known human
loss of function phenotype.
But it is has a profile that's
extremely similar to [INAUDIBLE]
on H1, telling us actually
with very high confidence that
heterozygous loss of function
mutations in this gene do
something, probably
something pretty nasty.
Probably resulting in some kind
of relatively severe human
disease phenotype.
The fact that we don't know what
that disease phenotype is yet
could mean one of two things.
We just haven't sequenced
the right people yet or
it could be that, in fact,
this results in embryo loss.
So heterozygous loss of
function results in people
dying before they can
actually be born.
So overall we identified
more than 3,000
genes with a near complete loss
of loss of function variants
compared to expectations.
We call these high in genes
with a high probability of loss
of function intolerance or
high pLI.
And that includes almost
all of the known genes,
where knocking at a single copy
is enough to cause disease.
But importantly,
more than 70% of these genes,
we have no idea what they do.
There's no associated
human phenotype.
In fact, for most of them,
we don't know what
the molecular function is.
And so we now prioritize
the genes extraordinarily
heavily when we start looking
at disease phenotypes.
And this has already proven
extremely useful in narrowing
down on genes in autism,
schizophrenia, and
a whole range of other very
nasty pediatric diseases.
So the last thing I wanted to
talk about was an example of how
we can use these large cohorts
to understand the precise impact
of individual variance within
a gene on disease risk.
And this work that's been led
by Eric Minikel, this was a very
personal project, for reasons
I'll describe in a minute.
And what
happened while Eric Minikel
was an analyst in my lab.
So Eric came to my lab extremely
motivated to work on a gene call
PRNP which includes
the prion protein.
And his motivation for
this was his wife, Sonia,
who's shown here.
Sonia is shown with her mother,
this photo was taken at the
beginning of 2010 when Sonia's
mother was completely healthy.
Over the course of that year,
she underwent a pretty
terrifying cognitive decline.
Went into frank dementia, and
awfully passed away at
the end of that year.
So it was about a nine-month
period between the onset of
symptoms and her dying.
At the time that she died,
it was completely unclear
what had actually killed her.
But on an autopsy, it was found
that her brain was full of
accumulations of a particular
protein called prion protein.
This is, in some cases,
a genetic disease.
So her prion protein
gene was sequenced.
She was found to carry a
mutation that was known to cause
in a dominant way, a very
severe disease prion disease
called Fatal Familial Insomnia.
So Sonia had a 50% chance
of actually carrying
that same mutation.
She then had, was faced
with a choice of whether or
not she wanted to
be tested herself.
Her mother had died in her 50s.
She was at the time
in her early 30s.
She and Eric thought about it
and then decided to go ahead and
get tested.
And in early 2011,
Sonia learned that she too
carries the same variant
that killed her mother.
So as far as we know,
everyone who carries this
particular variant has a 100%
chance of going on to
die from prion disease.
There's many ways of responding
to this kind of incredibly
catastrophic information.
Eric and Sonia responded in
a way that I, still to this day,
find inspiring.
They quit their jobs.
Eric at the time
was a town planner.
Sonia was a lawyer,
a Harvard-trained lawyer.
So they abandoned their
respective careers and
retrained completely as
biomedical scientists.
Initially with Sonia
training in the wet lab,
and Eric focusing on
bioinformatics work and that's
what they continue doing to this
day, as I'll show you later.
So when Eric came to my lab,
what he wanted to know more than
anything was an answer
to this question.
Given that Sonia carries
this particular mutation,
how likely is it that she will
go on to get prion disease.
This turns out to be
a little bit uncertain,
it is a question of what
we call penetrance.
That is the probability that a
carrier of a particular disease,
genotype, will actually go
on to manifest that disease.
This is known to be
incomplete and variable for
many disease causing mutations.
So, in BRCA1 for instance,
we know that woman who have
variance in this gene will go on
to have somewhere between a 60
to 80% chance of
contracting breast cancer.
But that has a big error
bars associated with it,
and not every woman who has a
BRCA1 mutation will go on to die
from breast cancer.
And in fact, for
most disease-causing variants,
even ones that are relatively
well-established,
we don't actually have a good
quantitative estimate of what
that penetrance is.
And that's also true for
prion disease.
So prion diseases we
know are relatively rare,
lifetime risk about 1 in 5,000.
85% of the cases, we have
no idea what causes them,
they appear to be sporadic.
But as I mentioned,
15% of these cases are genetic,
a notorious 1% of prion
disease cases are acquired.
And they can be acquired through
ingestion of contaminated meat
for instance qs was the case for
the variant Creutzfeldt-Jakob
disease outbreak in the UK, it
was caused by mad cow disease.
The genetic cases are due
to set of over sixty
known dominant gain of function
mutations in the gene.
And what's amazing about
this disease is that we have
incredibly good
surveillance data.
Basically everyone who is
diagnosed with prion disease
gets reported to
a surveillance center, and
for most of those individuals,
the prion gene is sequenced.
And so we have an almost
complete collection of genetic
information from diagnosed
prion disease cases across
the western world.
And so what Eric said about
doing was collecting a set of
information that would allow
us to compare the frequency of
these mutations in prion
disease cases versus controls.
So we started with a set
of population controls and
here we reasoned that completely
penetrant versions in aggregate
for a dominant disease should be
no more common in the population
than the disease
that they cause.
So that means that we can run
analysis even in a set of
samples like ExAC, where we
don't know exactly whether
people will go on to
get prion disease.
But we can assume relatively
confidently that the frequency
of prion disease causing
mutations in that
population will be no higher
than the actual frequency of
prion disease itself.
So we collected our 60,000
ExAC exomes all of whom had
effectively perfect coverage for
the prion gene.
We're also able to work with
23andMe, to bring in information
from about half a million
of their customers,
all of whom have
been genotyped for
16 reportedly disease-causing
stamps within that gene.
And then in a series of
feats of pretty remarkable
political jiu-jitsu, Eric was
able to collect over 10,500
cases of prion disease, who had
had the PR and P gene sequence.
This constitutes pretty
much every known or
probable prion disease case that
has appeared in the US, Europe,
Australia, and Japan for
the last 15 to 20 years.
It's the biggest collection of
rare disease cases that I have
ever worked with.
And probably the biggest
collection of cases
that we'll ever get for
something like prion disease.
So this is a really remarkable
data set to do a comparison on.
And so we can calculate pretty
easily how many individuals we
would expect to see in our
60,000 ExAC individuals, who
actually do have real variants
that will cause a prion disease.
And if you multiply these
slightly hand wavy numbers out,
you end up with a number that
is somewhere between one and
two individuals who carry a
mutation that will go on to kill
them of prion disease.
So that's the expected number,
the actual observed number
turns out to be much higher.
So we found 16
different mutations.
Sorry, sorry, I think it's 12
different mutations in PRNP that
had previously been reported
to be pathogenic and
52 individuals carried them.
So that's 30 times higher than
what we would expect to see,
given the frequency of
the disease in the population.
There's multiple possible
explanations here.
It could be that prion disease
is actually terrifyingly more
common than we think it is.
We're pretty confident
that's not the case.
So by far, the most likely
explanation is that some of
these previously
reported disease-causing
mutations actually don't
cause disease in everyone.
Or perhaps, in some cases,
don't cause disease in anyone.
They've been falsely reported
as being pathogenic.
So to explore that, we generated
a plot that looks like this,
and as well as a bunch of
statistical analysis that I'm
not gonna go through here.
This plot is very simple,
basically what is shows in
the x-axis is the number of
times we observed a particular
reported prion disease causing
a mutation in our cases.
So that basically tells us
how common it is in patients
who went on to get the disease.
And on the y-axis we have
the frequency of the same
variants in x-axis.
Again, a set of population
controls broadly representative
of the general population.
And the variants then fall up
to three broad categories.
Along the x-axis, we have
variants that are seen in cases,
but are seen never or
very rarely in controls.
These four variants along this
axis all turn out to be variants
with incredibly strong evidence
for actually being pathogenic
and disease-causing And as far
as we can tell, every individual
who has ever carried these
variants has indeed gone on to
die from prion disease if they
survive into their fifties.
And unfortunately that
does include D178N,
which is the variant
that Sonia carries.
On the y-axis, we have a set of
variants that are at relatively
low frequency in cases.
They're also at
relatively low frequency,
basically the same
frequency in controls.
So there's no information here
whatsoever to indicate that
these variants are actually
associated with prion disease.
And in fact certainly for these
variants that cluster up here,
we can very confidently rule
them out as having any effect
whatsoever on prion
disease risk at all.
So these are variants that have
accidentally been associated
with prion disease,
because they happened to be in
an individual who died from
sporadic prion disease, and
as a result they ended
up in the database.
And we can now in most
cases throw those away.
And then there's
a set of variants,
really interesting
variants in the middle,
who are too common in cases
to be completely benign, but
also too common in controls
to be fully pathogenic.
And these are variants that
clearly are a product of
incomplete penetrance, that is,
they cause diseases in some
people but not in others.
And we can calculate with
some confidence the actual,
absolute lifetime risk
of prion disease, for
people who carry each
of these mutations.
And that ranges enormously
from 1 in 1,000 risk for
this variant up here, but
still confidently above 0, and
down to about 10% risk for
this variant down here.
That has profound implications
for genetic counseling.
For all three of these variants,
there was information in the
literature that suggested that
there was incomplete penetrance,
but we had no idea what these
risk estimates actually were.
And now people who are working
with families affected by these
mutations can go back and
give them a relatively well
calibrated estimate of how
likely it is that another
family member who carries those
mutations will go on
to get the disease.
Just to give you an example
about how this information can
change lives,
there was an opinion piece that
accompanied the publication of
this prion disease work
back earlier last year.
And in that, Robert Green,
a clinician at Brigham and
Women's, describes a patient
that he was seeing at the time.
This patient's mother had died,
like Sonia's mother had died,
of prion disease.
It was unknown what
the cause was.
This patient had her
prion gene sequenced and
was found to carry
a mutation called E196A.
And she had been told as
a result that it was very likely
she would go on to die from
prion disease in her 50s.
It turns out that E196A is the
mutation for which we are by far
the most confident that this has
absolutely no association with
prion disease.
This is a completely
accidental finding.
And this woman, Robert was able
to return that data back to her.
He was also able to say that,
looking back
through the literature,
there is no information on
segregation of this variant
within prion disease families.
There is no family
history in patients who
carry that particular variant.
And the frequency is absolutely
no higher in cases than it is in
controls.
So her probability of going
on to get prion disease is no
higher than
the population average.
So basically, Robert was able
to commute a death sentence in
this particular case.
And that, of course,
can have transformative
impacts in other ways as well.
So this information did not
change, as far as we know,
Sonia's risk of going on
to get prion disease.
But I think it did, in many
ways, reestablish Eric and
Sonia's commitment to working
as hard as they can to come up
with a therapeutic approach to
reducing the levels of prion
protein in Sonia's brain.
To the level that it's actually
possible to ameliorate her risk
of going on to get
prion disease.
In this case,
the therapeutic target is
actually extremely clear.
If it's possible to get
a chemical agent into Sonia's
brain that reduces the overall
levels of native prion protein,
it's almost certain that she
will be able to
reduce that risk.
And Eric and
Sonia are now working at
a lab at the Broad Institute.
They're PhD students at Harvard,
but
amazingly have their own
lab at the Broad Institute.
They're working in collaboration
with a number of industry
partners to produce compounds
that will hopefully be able to
produce exactly that effect over
the next 10 to 15 years, which
is the time that Sonia has left
to come up with such a therapy.
And of course, we all wish
them the best in that quest.
So we have a lot of work to do
to be able to expand gnomAD to
be able to answer
similar questions for
a whole range of
other disease genes.
We're very interested in
continuing to expand this.
We will be expanding this to
over 65,000 whole human
genomes with a new
core set that will hopefully
be generated later this year,
calling structural variants
across the entire dataset.
And a set of analyses focused
on protein-truncating variants,
as well as looking at constraint
in non-coding regions.
And I think the key points
that it's worth emphasizing in
the context of this presentation
is, firstly, the naturally
occurring human genetic
variation is really useful for
understanding both the impact of
variation in a disease setting,
but also in terms of
understanding human biology.
That the more humans
we have sequenced and
phenotyped, and the more diverse
their ancestry, the better
off we are in terms of
understanding this disease risk.
That everyone carries
rare genetic variants.
And it's true that most
interesting variants are rare,
but it's also importantly true
that most rare variants are not
actually particularly
interesting.
And these large scale
reference databases
help to distinguish between
those two scenarios.
And finally, one of the things
that I think has been a real
strength of ExAc and
gnomAD has been,
we've been very fortunate to
benefit from a human genomics
community that's been willing to
share data openly and rapidly.
But there's still a lot of work
that we as a community can
do to make that process better.
And it's really only
with that open and
rapid data sharing that we can
build resources like this and
make them available
to the world.
So with that,
I'll finish by thanking
everyone who's been involved in
generating and analyzing
this important resource.
Again, including the analysis
team, production team at Broad,
the individuals who built the
gnomAD website, and once again,
the genomics platform and
the Hail team for
all of the critical work
in building this data out.
Thanks to you guys for
listening.
>> [APPLAUSE]